لا تزال هذه الأسئلة حول الرهائن قائمة،
ويبدو أن الاستعدادات لهجوم بري
في غزة جارية، دعنا
نلقي نظرة فاحصة على غزة مع الرائد المتقاعد في
الجيش الأمريكي مايك ليونز، أه كبير الأسود،
نقدر وجودك هنا للبدء، كما تعلم
أننا نسمع باستمرار عن مدى
ضيق الأمر  موجود في غزة لعدم وجود
مصطلح أفضل، حوالي مليوني شخص، وهي
منطقة بحجم شيكاغو تقريبًا. ما هي
المضاعفات التي يجلبها ذلك لأي
نوع من التأثير الأرضي، نعم أعني
هائلًا، وأعتقد أننا سنرى
احتمالية سقوط ضحايا
وخسائر في صفوف المدنيين مثلنا  لم نر منذ
الحرب العالمية الثانية فقط بناءً على ما
قالته إسرائيل إنهم أعلنوا الحرب
هنا قالوا استخدم كلمة مثل
Siege Siege من منظور عسكري
يعني تسطيح يعني أننا
سنحاصر الاختناق كما تعلم  الإمدادات
تنقطع هنا أريد أن أتحدث
قليلاً عن طاقم CNN الشجاع
لأنهم يجلسون هنا في
كفر أأأ
هنا وهم قريبون جدًا من حدود غزة هنا وما يوجد
تحته هو صاروخ  النيران
القادمة من الجانب الآخر لا تزال
لديها القدرة، حماس لا تزال تطلق
الصواريخ داخل إسرائيل، وعلى الرغم من أن
الإطارات الجوية التي تسمعها هي
قوات إسرائيلية في محطة ما على استعداد للاستعداد
لضربهم ولكن مرة أخرى
يظهر لي أنهم  لا تزال لديهم القدرة التي
لم يتوقفوا عنها فيما يتعلق
بمهاجمة إسرائيل. ما هي أكبر
التحديات التي تواجه القوات الإسرائيلية إذا
رأينا التوغل البري؟ أعتقد أن نيك
قدم نقطة جيدة للغاية لأنه كان لديه
سنوات من الخبرة في تغطية المنطقة
في تقديره.  إنهم لم
يحشدوا ما يكفي في هذه المرحلة للقيام
بتوغل وشيك، وهذه هي
قراءته على الأرض ولكن متى
حدث ذلك، ما هي
التحديات التي يواجهونها بمجرد دخولهم إلى
غزة، حسنًا، أعتقد أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن الأمر
سيستغرق  سيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت حتى ينتهوا
كجزء من عملية هجومية كبيرة
في الممر، وسيستغرق الأمر
أيامًا حتى تتم تعبئة 300000 جندي احتياطي،
وبمجرد دخولهم،
تعرف ما هي أهدافهم
هل سيهاجمون  من
جوانب مختلفة، هل سيأتون
من هذا الجانب هنا ليقطعوا قوات حماس؟
من الواضح أن هذا هو مركز
الثقل هنا فيما يتعلق بمكان
تواجد قوات حماس، لكنني أعتقد أن إسرائيل
يجب أن تشعر بقلق بالغ بشكل عام
بشأن الأمر من منظور استراتيجي  من وجهة نظري،
لديهم إمكانات، لديهم عدو هنا
قادم في هذا الاتجاه، لديهم
حزب الله قادم من الشمال،
وإذا تمكنوا من حشد القوات في الضفة الغربية،
فستكون هذه هي المشكلة هنا المتمثلة في
محاولة خوض حرب على ثلاث جبهات،
وهذا هو السبب  لقد استدعوا 300 ألف جندي
لذا عليهم أن يكونوا قادرين على وضع قوات
في كل هذه المواقع ولكن بمجرد
عودتهم إلى غزة بمجرد وصولهم إلى هذا
الموقع هنا، سيكون هناك
قتال في الشوارع من منزل إلى منزل ومرة ​​أخرى
خسائر كبيرة في صفوف المدنيين.  تحدث عن
الضربات التي رأيناها أه على
مدار الأيام القليلة الماضية كانت هناك
غارات جوية شهدت العديد من
الضربات في منشآت محددة للغاية على
الأقل وفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي وما هي
أهدافها ماذا يقول لك هؤلاء
نعم إنهم  إذا نظرت إلى
بعض الأشياء، فهذه هي المساجد الآن،
لذا فأنت تعلم أنهم يزيلون
كل شيء عن الطاولة فيما يتعلق بالأضرار
الجانبية مرة أخرى،
عادةً لن يهاجم الجيش
هذا النوع من الأهداف التي يقولونها
من الواضح أنها أهداف عسكرية أه
وفي هذه الحالة لن يتركوا شيئًا
خلفهم، كما تعلم في الماضي
سيكونون أكثر تمييزًا فيما يتعلق بما
سيتبعونه من أشياء محددة هنا فهم
حرفيًا جميع أنواع
الأهداف التي يستهدفونها  سنذهب بعد ذلك، ولم
يبق شيء بعد، وهذان
المسجدان اللذان تعرضهما نعم، وقبل وبعد قبل وبعد،
نعم يوم السبت، تم
إطلاق بعض الصواريخ من هوسب وجنوب
لبنان على إسرائيل، ثم كان هناك القليل
من  توقف مؤقتًا، قال وزير الخارجية
لينكولن، ثم رأيت بالأمس
المزيد، هل يمكنك التحدث عن
التعقيد المتمثل في محاولة محاربة
حزب الله في شمال إسرائيل بينما
تقوم بالباقي، نعم، هذا هو
ما يجب على إسرائيل أن تقلق بشأنه حقًا
لأنه سيتعين عليهم ذلك  ضعوا قوات في
الشمال هنا، وهذا هو المكان الذي
سيأتون فيه من هنا وبعد ذلك
سيتم تقديمه أيضًا، لقد حذرنا الآن
الحكومة السورية التي تقول انظروا
إذا قرر حزب الله الدخول
وهم مقاتلون جيدون  لقد
كانوا جزءًا من الحرب الأهلية السورية،
ولديهم هذا النوع من الخبرة،
ومن ثم فإن ذلك يفتح جبهة محتملة
تصبح فيها دمشق هدفًا في هذه
المنطقة هنا، وأعتقد أن إسرائيل ستضطر
إلى نشر قوات برية
هناك.  ما هي ميزة إسرائيل هنا
في هذه الحرب التقليدية هو تأثير الصدمة، فهم
يجلبون الدبابات ويجلبون القوة الجوية.
المشكلة هي أن العدو لا يخوض
هذا النوع من المعارك التقليدية بالضبط، هذا
كل شيء، وهنا
يبدأ الأمر برمته، كما تعلم أنهم
يستعدون لها  حرب لم يحصلوا عليها
وهذا هو سبب وجودهم في
الوضع الآن ما هي
قدرات HB أه مقارنة بحماس
لأن الأمس أفضل أفضل أكثر أه
لديهم قدرة أكبر مرة أخرى لا يزال
ليس لديهم تأثير الصدمة حقًا
لكنهم'  إعادة مقاتلين جيدين وهناك
المزيد منهم، يجب على إسرائيل أن تشعر
بالقلق، وهذا يخلق الآن إذا
جاءوا من الشمال هنا
والهجوم هنا قادم من
الجنوب، وهذا يخلق الآن
السيناريو الكابوس لعام 1973 للهجوم على  كلتا
الجبهتين بخير يا الرائد مايك ليونز، نحن
نقدر ذلك ونشكرك